GORAN HANSSON: The Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences
has decided to award the 2016
Nobel Prize in Physics
with one half to David J. Thouless
and the other half
to F. Duncan Haldane and
J. Michael Kosterlitz
for theoretical discoveries of
topological phase transitions
and topological phases of matter.
[MUSIC]
F. DUNCAN HALDANE: I introduced
interesting models that
demonstrated unexpected
topological effects in quantum
mechanics at a time when
no one really -- very few people
had been thinking about
topological -- that quantum mechanics
could have a topological aspect.
And topology has led to, leads to
a remarkable stability of these effects
and very interesting effects of the boundary
between so-called normal matter
and topological matter that
has lots of possibilities.
So this partly introduced
a new way of thinking.
Off to class!
I think you never set out to do it.
You can't say, I'm going to wake up
this morning and discover something big.
You get led by, of course there's
some pathway that
leads you in that direction,
and you have to kind of
be persistent enough to notice that you've
found something interesting, right,
and get intrigued by it
and explore it more.
Quantum mechanics
can do amazing things
and we don't really --
People always say how mysterious
quantum mechanics is
but it's only now, really, this century,
we're now starting to actually
manipulate things quantum mechanically.
And we're going to discover all kinds of
stuff that we don't really understand it.
We know how to do calculations but these
topological effects are examples
of things that no one
really had dreamt of.
Someone had to initially find these
things but it can take time.
[CHEERS, APPLAUSE]
It's a graduate class.
Hopefully it will be
inspirational for the
graduate students.
STEVEN LI: I just heard
this morning.
My friend texted me, and
I realized that I have his class
in two hours, and I was just so
overwhelmed that he maintained his class.
It's just a completely different feeling
sitting in front of a Nobel laureate.
F. DUNCAN HALDANE: It's all
due to your inspiration.
JOSEPH TAYLOR: This is really great.
Congratulations.
F. DUNCAN HALDANE:
Thank you.
This is the man who
made it all possible for me
by giving me inspiration
to follow in his footsteps.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
As a former student of physics
myself at Princeton,
one of my strongest memories
of my undergraduate years here
was the day in 1980 when Val Fitch
won the Nobel Prize in Physics.
It was a wonderful moment for the
department and for the University,
a celebration of the truly
groundbreaking work
that goes on here,
and as an undergraduate
I felt privileged simply to
have a chance to watch
the excitement from the sidelines.
When I was up late at night,
struggling through difficult
problem sets in Fine Library,
I would occasionally
seek inspiration by walking through
the halls of the physics building
and gazing at the portraits of
the many Nobel laureates
who had studied in the department
or served on its faculty.
I am delighted today
to see this marvelous tradition
extended as Professor Duncan Haldane
becomes the newest addition
to this extraordinary department's
"hall of fame."
LYMAN PAGE: It's hard to
just say a few words.
What an absolutely wonderful
colleague he is to have
on so many fronts.
And this is, of course, a wonderful prize
but it's especially wonderful
that it went to Duncan.
So, cheers!
Here's to you, Duncan, and here's to
many more prizes for your colleagues.
DIANA VALVERDE MENDEZ:
We were taking
the ENM prelim prep course
with Professor Haldane.
Last Thursday, I had a doubt
about the subject,
and he stayed with me,
like, the whole lunch hour
just trying to figure out
what it was about.
He's really approachable and a very
nice person, and I'm very glad for him.
M. ZAHID HASAN: Duncan is
along the tradition of
some of the best, wonderful theoretical
physicists we have at Princeton.
This is in line with the tradition
and we're very much excited about it.
RAJEEV ERRAMILLI:
It's kind of surreal to
be an undergraduate in a place where
there's so many people doing
such amazing, incredible work
and getting international recognition.
[MUSIC]